puisse continuer à lutter contre la
corruption merci la parole est à
monsieur debré monsieur le premier
ministre
cela fait plusieurs semaines qu à paris
nantes et rennes des casseurs détruit
spi lancent des cocktails molotov et
frappe des policiers au sol après avoir
enlevé leur casque comme pour les tuer
les voici maintenant qu'ils brûlent des
voitures de police on assiste à une
véritable chasse aux policiers le bilan
on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
des centaines de vitrines et commerces
détruits 350 blessés parmi les forces de
l'ordre
un véritable état insurrectionnel dans
certaines villes de france
qui sont ces casseurs sont-ils
clairement identifiés connu est fiché
l'état d'urgence permet-il de tels
débordements
que se passe-t-il l'état aurait-il
abdiquer face à la grogne d'une extrême
gauche ultra violente
attisées par des syndicalistes qui
injurie gravement les policiers quelle
image pour notre pays sur la scène
internationale alors que l'euro 2016
débute dans moins d'un mois
monsieur le premier ministre toutes ces
questions la représentation nationale se
dépose tout comme la très grande
majorité des français qui ne comprend
pas que l'on puisse ainsi laisser faire
même si ça fait longtemps qu'ils ont pu
constater la faiblesse d'un président ou
remarquer que vous parliez beaucoup
lorsque vous répondez à l'opposition
sont beaucoup agir
et lorsque vous injuriez vos frondeurs
de votre parti et qu'il n'ya plus
d'unité dans gouvernement entre vous et
votre ministre de l'économie or quand il
n'y a plus de pouvoir
c'est la re qui le prend et le fait dans
la violence faiblesse partout et à nulle
part le président a apporté son soutien
aux policiers
on attendait comme un pain qu'il apporta
son soutien aux casseurs
le ministre de l'intérieur vient de le
faire aux à marolles est à monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député debré
vous êtes parfaitement au courant de ce
qu'est dans le temps long de l'histoire
de la vème république les soirs des
manifestations et vous savez que les
casseurs ne sont pas nés avec les
manifestations récentes
j'ai fait faire un petit bilan
extrêmement précis des dégâts
occasionnés par les casseurs à
l'occasion par exemple du cpe et au
moment du cpe il ya eu énormément de
casse j'ai fait un bilan extrêmement
précis de ce qu'a été l'action des
casseurs pendant les trois semaines
d'émeutes urbaines de 2005 à l'occasion
desquelles il y avait un ministre de
l'intérieur qui semble inspirer vos
questions et à ce moment là vous ne
théorise y est pas la chienlit ni la
faiblesse du président de la république
de l'époque
et moi je vous demande simplement
monsieur debré d'essayer de faire en
sorte que je suis sur ces sujets là on
fasse un peu moins de politique et qu'on
soit davantage dans la responsabilité
collective
et si vous étiez dans la responsabilité
vous reconnaîtriez en saluant leur
travail que les forces de l'ordre depuis
le début de ce mouvement ont procédé à
l'interpellation de 1300 personnes que
819 d'entre elles ont été placées en
garde à vue et que les tribunaux sont en
train de les juger
et au moment où deux policiers ont été
pris à partie par des casseurs qui ont
brûlé leur voiture en mettant en danger
leur vie
vous reconnaîtrez aussi le travail qui
est fait par la justice et les policiers
pour mettre fin aux agissements de ces
individus qui doivent être condamnés
pour ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire des
casseurs et pour ce qu'ils font c'est à
dire des exactions et je veux dire
devant la représentation nationale avec
la plus grande clarté que ce qui
explique aujourd'hui à l'opinion
publique dans un climat de tension que
face aux casseurs il ya eu 10 fermeté ni
interpellation manque aux français ils
mentent aux français
délibérément pour des raisons
petite politique
merci